[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are
currently off the record and lucky
enough to have with us lawrence cow as a
guest lauren
yay lawrence thank you
welcome you're welcome
dude um we were talking earlier about
men communicating and then you said
something
about how bart is bad at texting this
[ __ ] guy dude
every time he texts me i never know if
it's intended for me nick dunn
or some other guy
whose name is nick bear nick bear is a
he's a he's a fitness youtuber or nicki
rodriguez or nick rodriguez yeah another
another both these guys are all jacked
as [ __ ] they're big ass dudes they're
very
popular in their field but he will
always text me
with texts intended for those guys that
happens a lot for years i don't know why
but like those no you know why dude
those numbers pop up the same time right
so i like text nick i'm like hey all
right cool i'll see you in austin and
then next like what are you talking
about i'm like i thought i'm gonna go
see you in austin soon he goes dude
you're texting the wrong person
i know exactly dude i know exactly when
he's texting somebody else i was like is
this for me or is it for nick bear or
i'll be like hey it's me nick bear bart
go [ __ ] yourself
[Laughter]
hey my name is nick bear uh i hate you
don't ever talk to me again give me my
number and then he's like lol
why don't you just make a group chat
with all the nicks in your phone you
know what's the funniest thing so uh
cause this has happened today
yesterday i texted alex i was like hey
costa i was like we have here i texted
alex and i was like hey you want to go
train tomorrow and then alex text back
oh yeah i'm down and then i'm messing
around i'm gonna set a world record and
then alex sets back i'm gonna squat 135
and then i'm like
i was just i was laughing right and then
i talked to alex who who showed up
yesterday i'm like so i'll see you at
the gym he's like wait what are you
talking about and i'm like i thought
we're gonna go train tomorrow and then
he's like oh yeah i'm down a train okay
cool and then so uh this morning
alex acosta texts me and then he's like
hey i'm not gonna be able to train have
to take my sister to the school or
whatever i'm like oh no always i go to
the gym and then nadim's like hey alex
is here waiting for you i'm like what
are you talking about alex and cause i
have to take his sister to school and he
goes no the other alex
he invited the other alex
resurrect
wires are super cross i was like
oh [ __ ]
i'm afraid we look at bart's phone but
that's how down alex is he's down he was
like oh yeah i'll come to the gym dumb
there and then now when he says in squad
135 it all makes sense because the owls
of course is [ __ ] strong as [ __ ] so i
was like i was coasting the power lifter
alex's resurrection is a regular person
so did you end up working out with alex
yeah they didn't working out together
did you tell the story
you got to be honest man
you didn't tell them right now alex
doesn't know he's gonna watch his
[ __ ] video be like yeah really
inviting
did you actually want another lawrence
on today
i just show up and then you're like the
other lauren's like go away
how does that happen because he doesn't
have people's last names alex on the on
the search i don't know you need friends
with more diverse names
or first last name easy fix yeah maybe
first laughs so look i'll type in alex
right
all first names dude no last name
there's three different alexes with the
first name bro there's the [ __ ] out of
you so you memorized my numbers you
don't even write don't you have a kid
bro there's
one of them has a last name look dude
don't don't show don't show the the name
because they're going to know who that
is there's three different alex's no
last names oh
[Laughter]
that's how names work huh
oh
you know how i keep keep them separated
my mind i go by the area code but then i
just clicked the wrong that's more work
oh [ __ ] let's try it
who's
evelyn
but look you know what the worst part
about this
lake bear is is listed as nick bear
right right and i'm just nick
but he still texts nick as if he's
texting nick bear or the world famous
grappler mickey rodriguez right so he'll
text him he one time he texted me
sending a text to nick rodriguez
but i'm like hey bro what are you
talking about i was like my brother my
little brother did not win adcc trials
this past weekend
i was like okay bro your little
brother's [ __ ] crushing it and i was
like is this for nikki rod question mark
question mark question mark
the little brother you never knew you
had
my little mexican brother
who lives in austin texas
so if if this problem got fixed and it
never happened anymore wouldn't you miss
it i would that'd be sad but how can you
never text nick bear again
if you don't ever ask me about
distribution products for your
supplements
i was like bart that's a [ __ ] up joke
you know i don't have supplement line
keep up with what he's doing in his life
i'm wondering how many people bart
actually talked to thinking he'd talk to
you about [ __ ] like ryan ryan and mae
ryan
and i was like yeah i told you already
and it's like
what about the ryan's or the ryan's well
that happened to me remember i came on
days i wasn't supposed to
cause it because the call sheet just
said right i was like i'll be there yeah
yeah yeah oh that's right you were
filming what does that one
there's like seven people in here
that's crazy
no three ryan's but i've never mixed
those ones up
i guess us nicks just look alike dude
maybe because those ryan's have last
names or different area codes right or
well yours is under anime probably oh
cool so that's his weight maybe if you
had to make nick's a longer oh there's
four ryan's they all got last names too
the last names bro it's come for you to
receive a nickname in your in his phone
yeah what do you want what do you want
him to call he should do it right now we
should make it happen he has to pick it
yes when do you guys actually put their
full names
in the contacts immediately yeah right
in the beginning yeah
or especially if they have a very like
common name yeah no i i think that's to
me is a rite of passage it's like okay
we're friends now
we're like i think i'm gonna continue
talking to you oh so but then but then
do you have like a lot of so do you end
up eventually deleting a lot of numbers
then or do they just exist on they exist
but i just don't you don't even save
their name yet i don't need to yeah when
do you add a photo to me it's like junk
mail yeah huh do you ever add a photo i
thought that comes with their settings
yeah it does like your iphone right yeah
every
girlfriend joe ever had it's their name
and then i put gitzicolathen
i do that to my friends that's how i do
it with my friends all my friends
girlfriends i do that it's like this
person i just automatically put their
last name yeah
[Laughter]
and then you don't change it so their
last name's still the same and they're
like he's got a lot of ex-wives they get
all mad would you bring her up
well how are you gonna fix this
i'll change that nick done i'm pretty
sure dunn's in there
are there other ones just nick it's just
nick in there i don't know what i have
nick as i think it's the ear oh no i
don't have the last name in there see
there it is do you ever save people's
like
as the ins because you don't know their
names
yeah oh it's nick dunn and it's got a
purple background with a face
guy that's me dude
you chose that one right i don't know i
think it's automatic i don't know how to
get rid of oh yeah mine says mine's
nicky here too that's my number you want
to show the camera
show my contact all right it's
that's it there i bet it's still going
to happen though no i hope it does i
hope it's still there
i think i'm going to live for that i
want i want that moment just to happen
every now and then are you going to meet
up and then you're going to buy i'll be
an awesome
i'll be like
when i was supposed to go to austin i
was like tripping out for a second
can you call me real quick so you can
see the photo i put for your
how do you know let's see i always want
to test if it works
if he calls you
he'll see the photo you put for him well
i'm going to show him physically in the
real world in a second
doesn't even have my number i do and
it's your actual name conferrido wow
government
kind of docks me dude
they could see the number nah there's no
number on here look
i'm calling you you is this a different
ryan it's just not picking up at all
yeah oh there it is oh there yeah look
oh look see look at your face that makes
it easy show bart you can do that
oh wait it's not his face
it's a little picture of my face look at
the ear oh he took a picture you just
took it right now
i was like where was i wearing that hat
dude up to date dude
i don't confuse myself yeah no
definitely that's the latest picture
yeah you could do that what's the worst
uh text you ever sent on accident holy
[ __ ]
i was like i'ma [ __ ] thrust my dick
so deep into that [ __ ] [ __ ] destroy
it and then your mom goes and my mom was
like what's a [ __ ]
really you said that to your mom kidding
just kidding
oh man that'd be crazy one time i was uh
texting
i was texting my wife about the handyman
that for our place and his name is
miguel and he's really dope and i really
like him a lot because he's a sweetheart
and i was texting her and i was like i
think i'm in love with this miguel guy
this dude's the [ __ ] i love this dude
and i sent it to him on accident
and then and then he and then i'm like
oh [ __ ] my heart like [ __ ] stopped
for a second he didn't make it a joke
and then i was like i was like my bad
dude that's meant for my wife and then
he goes he goes he goes lol at least it
was good things you had to say
but at the moment i was like oh [ __ ]
this looks like you're trying to run
yeah yeah i'm trying to play my handyman
dude today's video is brought to you by
feels cbd is not about what you feel
it's about what you do not feel such as
stress out pain out anxiety and my
favorite is also sleeplessness
so sometimes i mean i'm not choice for
being able to fall asleep like that
right the minute it's 9 30 i'm like oh
so easy i go to sleep but then i've been
realizing the days i'm actually way more
stressed out from work i do wake up at
like 2 a.m sometimes really yeah and
then i'm like uh oh i need to be rested
because i need to work tomorrow so i
don't want to be up i want to
just sleep the whole seven or eight
hours and what i notice is taking little
feels before i go to sleep even if i
don't feel anxiety or anything like that
or even if i'm notorious for
sleeplessness it helps me i mean uh for
falling asleep fast it helps me kind of
ensure that i have a nice smooth sleep
process
that's pretty nice and feels if you
never did if you've never done cbd or
anything like that before fields has a
hotline where you can call in and be
like hey check it out kind of
intimidating kind of embarrassed i don't
know what to do here and they'll walk
you through the process and let you know
what's probably going to be a good dose
for you start feeling better with feels
become a member today by going to
fields.com off the record and you'll get
50 off your first order with free
shipping that's f e a l s dot com slash
off the record to become a member and
get 50
automatically taken off your first order
plus free shipping fields feels.com
off the record
like oops sorry wrong questions
oopsies how embarrassing is so i was
like
oh [ __ ] dude
so how did it go when you guys linked up
again it was fine he it was i felt it
was a a little bit weird but i think it
was i was just insecure i think it was
fine
professional because that's the guy he
is shout out to miguel he's the man bro
he can fix anything this guy's the best
was he like topless when he was like
he's like hey man what's up dude
how's it going man i was like biting my
lip the whole time
i was like i gotta get out of here we're
gonna house ourselves so you really
meant what you said on that text
so do you think you're really loving me
[Laughter]
you probably have a ton of wrong text if
you don't realize you're wrong huh
i wouldn't know if they're wrong but
when it comes to like
like actual messages that are important
i think i'm pretty careful
but also
the messages you send us are important
jim beating with
he's like oh you want to go here and go
over there
people invited them wrong
he invited the wrong dude had a full
conversation
i remember there was a there was a point
where i was i was hanging with a buddy
and he was like i'm lonely tonight i'm
gonna i'm gonna hit up brittany to come
cuddle hits up the wrong brittany
wrong brittany comes over oh to cuddle
we were both like what the [ __ ] what's
she doing here
and then he was like oh [ __ ]
she stayed over and he hooked up anyway
was she was she like uglier or she's
more annoying just she was just a
different one
was she less preferred well the the
shocking thing is they didn't have a
rapport like that so she was just down
oh but she was just dying wow it was
just down i think she's been crushing on
them she's like finally exactly and we
were just like how the [ __ ] did that
happen
yeah i was like dude pretty good turnout
best case scenario that is a happy
accident and i love happy accidents
wow
yeah i don't think i put last names for
britney's yeah dude especially when you
have multiple girls i knew i knew guys
that like
they would travel all the time and they
would just have girls names and then the
city that they live in oh yeah and they
just do that everywhere they go and i
was and they they would show me the
rolodex and i was like
wow you know a lot of people in
different cities i don't even know half
these places were even like real cities
you know it's you know it's a fun game
to play
is uh we used to call it uh it was
called text roulette or like call
roulette call roulette you basically let
someone have your phone and then they do
this and then you say stop and then
whatever name they're on on the context
they call it you don't get to see it you
gotta talk to them and figure out who
you're talking to without asking who
this is that's so stressful that's a
gangster [ __ ] that's a crazy and the
faster you can do it like that's your
record like you gotta get the record oh
that's a good game
and if they have any indication that
you're being weird you lose
i want to call justin chan
it's funny to do it and be like who you
would have called oh that's so scary
i don't even know these people
but it's just i don't have to talk to
them like that call right now text them
hey justin can we do it with yours your
phone yeah it's not your phone dude oh
[ __ ]
if it's a handyman
miguel again he's like yo dude you can't
keep calling me like go like this like
crazy and then we'll say stop because
i've had the same number stop uh i
already got to the end you gotta do it
you know
no nobody did this
stop nobody who you want
i don't know who this person is called
oh
you don't know who that is
i don't know what this is called
i'm calling it oh i'm gonna call him
call him and figure it out i'm calling
him already you got it you gotta call
you gotta talk to him but it's your
number they're gonna know it's you
everybody
are you really letting us do the [ __ ]
can i show them the name
i don't know
so why do you have his number i don't
know
who's that andrew hyun andrew hyun
people don't pick up phone calls anymore
voicemail
yeah hello
this guy don't have voice music two
oh they're just gonna leave the number
[Laughter]
quick thinking quick thinking i'm gonna
come out
we could have muted we could have muted
it do you know that yeah you want
someone else gotta do one oh man i can't
do it i'm scared i can't do it either
point and see who it pointed to and is
it someone you've talked to or tell us a
story about it
okay it might be a crazy story because
there's a second level to this game
that's level one oh my god you guys are
crazy the second level is in your
conversation
people have to show you words and you
have to incorporate it into conversation
oh wow so like
and they can't feel like there's
something weird right when you're
talking right so you can't like so if i
would if i were to go like this and it
says like latte and i point to it you
gotta add latte to what you're saying
but you gotta hide it so they don't if
they go why are you saying that then you
lose
you create jk party you guys are so
crazy nuts because you end up like
really burning some bridges sometimes
and you can't so you can't you can't
talk to them about it afterwards and be
like no i called you because of this
thing it's better not to like the
biggest bridge you've ever burned doing
that doing that yeah i think just like x
is double downing on thinking how weird
i am
because it'll always land on an x like
something about that and then you have
their number
yeah you're like why is he calling me
and then they're like because you sound
like a [ __ ] crazy guy like someone
will point to ginkgo biloba and you got
to say that
[Laughter]
we'll do we'll do the thing where you
got to point out this phone won't even
pick up dude no not try it try to try it
he might pick up if it's you right so
he's got to incorporate words you point
to i don't know any of these people and
most of these are emails
wait why is it always facetime facebook
downloaded my whole email list
try this game dude it's [ __ ] up never
picks up let's see he doesn't gilbert
watch he picks up
we'll see well because you guys work
together
it's got to be printed on something or
it doesn't count
most of these are emails
[Music]
come on gilbert [ __ ] pick up flaming
no just flaming blaming
flaming hot
i like the i like the intensity of like
if they're going to pick up oh yeah come
on
i'll talk to him like this yeah
gilbert has a whack-ass voicemail
[Laughter]
wow that's how it's done oh this game is
scary you guys play this all the time
no we don't it's it's damaging we played
it you stopped playing this and who came
up with it stop playing like i did but
we stopped playing like 10 years you
came up with it yeah because it's like
super socially damaging
people just think you're a [ __ ]
lunatic business relationships how long
have you had that number for which
number the one on your phone forever
i have [ __ ] like 15 years of people i
know in here some of the names i look at
i'm like oh [ __ ] i don't think i've had
another number other than when i was
like
this is my first cell phone number when
i got a cell phone
wow that's like 20 years old it's old
same reminder i have a lot of uh emails
though that i don't even recognize so i
think my icloud download been a whole
[ __ ] gmail list it did it synced with
your gmail yeah then that's gonna make
it even worse because there might be a
business
contact wait they called back naws one
of the guys we had to fire before
oh he's calling gill's calling back
he is
[Music]
hello
hi i'm just returning this call is this
the uh dropped up okay ceo
that was the worst impression of
something
that much
that was weird that was a weird ucb [ __ ]
dude was it
and probably the improv is flaming hot
dude have you been toy theater there's
no improv anymore there's no improving
what are you talking about what's the
what's the most common form of comedy
now
it's jk news baby jk news is the new
tabasco you're right about that
we're just filming uh we're filming this
um this new mixed nuts commercial for
just kidding news
and
yeah we have to do like this roulette of
phone numbers and whatever and then
whatever name pops up i have to click it
and then i have to
i have to call it
i have to call it to know that um
and see who's gonna answer it sometimes
it could be third street athletics
well i'm honored with the random numbers
do i get paid for this or what uh
yes well we'll send you some free
disinfecting wipes
uh let's go uh i'll see you for the time
yes no you're not being i didn't start
talking about allergies going quit nuts
you're so [ __ ] dumb
[Laughter]
i'll tell you back after i told you
what the [ __ ] is this show anymore dude
oh you're in the middle of a tiger belly
shoot
what you got
well you guys should call us then and
then we can have
show sets
that's the power block thing to do
[Laughter]
you actually made it kind of make sense
to the conversation what i'm saying
third street athletics
sometimes you gotta call third street
athletics
he was saying you're really good at that
you're an all-star girl it's crazy oh my
god
yeah and it was all kinds of genres dude
from everything and it's hard because
he's very prone to go what the [ __ ] are
you talking about yeah yeah like he's
that guy yeah i'm doing i'm being normal
what are you calling me you carried a
good conversation the whole time he's
always feeling a mixed nuts commercials
are you kidding me what the [ __ ]
dude i'm gonna send this video too
you're like yeah gilbert it is weird
that is a [ __ ] outrageous thing
[Music]
you